acompañado por el escuadrón
antiterrorista de indonesia
abu bakar bashir dejó la prisión como un
hombre libre el viernes el hombre de 82
años es sospechoso de estar detrás de
los ataques en bali en el año 2002 pero
las autoridades nunca pudieron probar su
participación
bachir era el líder espiritual de una
red ligada al qaeda responsable de las
bombas que dejaron a más de 200 muertos
en dos bares el clérigo radical había
sido encarcelado por las explosiones
anteriormente pero más tarde se anuló su
condena de apelación
bashir ha negado repetidamente su
implicación en 2011
bashir fue sentenciado a 15 años por
financiar el entrenamiento de militantes
pero recibió reducciones de pena y sólo
estuvo diez años en prisión el primer
ministro australiano scott morrison dijo
que su puesta en libertad sería muy
angustiosa para los amigos y familiares
de las víctimas 88 de ellas australianas
este hombre perdió a cinco amigos en las
explosiones
y todavía hay gente incluso la próxima
semana con operaciones por las
quemaduras la gente sigue sufriendo
muchos están lidiando con dolor cada año
mientras estaba en prisión en 2014
bashir prometió lealtad al estado
islámico las autoridades indonesias
dijeron que entraría en un programa de
desradicalización pues su influencia en
círculos extremistas generaba
preocupación